Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Menschen, die sich in der Welt verbreiten.
Chaosradio im letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Heute geht es um die Dinge, mit denen die Politik versucht, das Netz so zu machen, dass es schön sauber und geradeaus ist. So eine Art Einfamilienhaussiedlung. Wie das passieren soll, das sprechen wir heute zu Gastin Frank Rieger, Konstanze Kurz und Skusi. Guten Abend nochmal. Und ihr seid natürlich nach wie vor aufgerufen, hier anzurufen, wenn ihr mit diskutieren wollt, wenn ihr eine Meinung zum Thema habt oder wenn ihr Fragen habt, weil euch was nicht klar geworden ist. Und es geht ja letztendlich, das große Thema heute, Umgang der Politik mit Netzthemen oder mit dem bösen Internet, was ganz frei und wild ist. Und dazu will uns auch der Thomas was sagen. Hallo Thomas.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend wünsche ich euch. Ja, ich würde ganz gerne mal einsteigen in der Diskussion nochmal zum Jugendwiener Staatsvertrag zu bekommen. Ich habe ja immer noch so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass vielleicht eines der Länder den entsprechenden Ministerpräsidenten zu einem Nein bewegen kann. Ich muss gestehen, ich bin, sollte vielleicht meine politische Herkunft dazu sagen, ich bin Liberaler. Ich bin bei den Newies ziemlich aktiv. Ich habe da bei der CDU ziemliche Bedenken, dass es da einen Ministerpräsidenten geben wird, der da einen Nein kriegt. Aber wenn die SPD sowieso gerade mal dabei ist, sich mal ernsthaft zu überlegen, ob das mit ihrer Netzpolitikverhaltensweise in den letzten Jahren das Richtige war, dann wäre vielleicht ein Schritt in der Richtung, zu sagen, wir stimmen diesem jungen Medienstaatsvertrag nicht zu. Vielleicht schon mal der erste Schritt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eines der SPD-Länder geben wird, die in der Lage sind, das Ding aufzuhalten. Aber ich überlege, das Abstimmungsverhalten bei diesem Staatsvertrag dürfte wahrscheinlich ähnlich sein wie im Rat.
Glaubst du, dass die Liberalen eventuell in den Ländern, wo sie an der Regierung beteiligt sind, nicht vielleicht auch noch? Sie haben sich ja sehr klar geäußert.
Ja, also ich meine, ich habe in Niedersachsen dafür Lobbying gemacht. Ich habe als erst rausgekommen und habe schon mit den entsprechenden Leuten direkt hier in Niedersachsen telefoniert, die dafür zuständig sind und die sagten mir dann, das war, wie ihr vorhin gesagt habt, das ist erstmal irgendwie völlig unterm Radar. Da kann man denen teilweise echt nicht mal einen Vorwurf machen, weil das eben ein Geheimklümmel da ist. Und ja, mein Gott, dann habe ich mit denen telefoniert und die so, was ist denn das für ein Blödsinn so? Und dann ruft man an als Bürger und sagt denen irgendwie, wie die Welt funktioniert und die sagen so, hä, das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein.
Und haben die Julis sich da, also auch offiziell, also eure Jugendorganisation sich positioniert?
Wir haben Presse, also unser Bundesvorstand hat sich positioniert und hat gesagt, wir sind dagegen, wir haben noch keinen Antrag dagegen. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie den nächsten Bundeskongress, ich habe ehrlich gesagt, das haben wir uns geschafft, zeitlich, wegen zu vielen Themen, da auch noch einen Antrag zuzuschreiben, weil immerhin unser Bundesvorstand sich da schon positioniert hat, nämlich klar dagegen. Für mich waren jetzt irgendwie die Netzsperren und jetzt auch die EU-Netzsperren, da haben wir einen Dringlichkeitsantrag zu und den werden wir auch auf den Bundesparteitag einbringen und so. Also da sind wir dabei, da sind wir am Ball. Aber das Problem ist natürlich, dieses Ding irgendwie zu kippen erstmal, also denjenigen, die den Stabverteidigung fahren, vor allem. Das ist ein Land, was ein klares Nein ist und das Problem, das ist für manchen vielleicht auch nicht so ganz klar, wo ich nochmal drauf ausfülle, das Problem ist, wenn man eine Koalition in einem Land hat. Das ist zumindest der Ursus im Bundesrat so, wenn sich in der Koalition die beiden Partner uneinigt sind und auch nicht einigen wollen sozusagen, der eine sagt ja, der andere nein, dann ist es Ursus sich zu enthalten. Eine Enthaltung allerdings ist kein Nein. So und in dem Moment rutscht das durch, auch wenn sozusagen angenommen wir haben einen Teil der Koalition der kompletten Nein sagt und der da auch wirklich drauf beharrt und anderen der sagt ja, dann kommt es am Ende trotzdem durch, weil es kein ganzes Nein ist, sondern nur so ein Hals ist sozusagen.
Wir kennen das ja aus dem Bundesrat im Prinzip, da ist es ja so ähnlich, wenn die Gesetze zustimmungsfähig sind. Naja gut, also wir haben natürlich auch mitbekommen, dass die Julis sich gegen die Initiative der Malström-Kommissarin gewendet haben. Also das heißt, ihr Vater ja eigentlich offenbar dieselbe Linie wie die meisten Jugendorganisationen der Parteien. Also das ihr sagt, Netzperren wollen wir nicht. Ich glaube auch, dass da die Problematik ganz gut angekommen ist. Aber beim Jugendmedienstaatsvertrag scheint es ein bisschen, das scheint mir jetzt auch von dem, was du sagst, so ein bisschen dieser Joker hin und her geschoben wird. Ja, wir können nicht so richtig, die Liberalen könnte ja eigentlich mal die SPD machen. Aber die SPD sagt, die sind doch sowieso jetzt in der Regierung, die Liberalen.
Es gibt da schon Bestrebungen, auch von unseren Seiten aus. Mein persönlicher letzter Stand ist, dass die niedersachsenische Landesspitze sich irgendwie an die CDU gewandt hat. Und die gesagt haben... Mein letzter Stand war, dass sich unsere Landesspitze an die CDU gewandt hat, die gesagt hat, ihr könntet das mal besser lassen, das ist Blödsinn. Und die CDU gesagt hat, wir finden das aber ganz toll, ihr könnt das mal.
Wir kennen die Problematik ja aus dem Bund genauso.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie gegen eine Wand laufen. Ich sage immer, konservative Betonköpfe, da ist manchmal echt wenig zu machen. Also es ist ein schwieriges Ding. Ich wünsche mir manchmal, dass dort vernünftige Leute in der CDU mal rangelassen werden. Also jetzt in der neuen Bundesregierung, vielleicht habt ihr nachher Lust, noch mal über das Thema Orketkommission zu sprechen. Da gibt es ja jetzt eine Kommission, die sich um diesen ganzen Themenbereich Netzpolitik kümmern soll.
Ja, die wird schon im nächsten Monat eingesetzt. Also das ist ja quasi jetzt schon beschlossen über alle Fraktionen hinweg.
Die Union hat jetzt zwei, drei sehr netzpolitisch kompetente Leute im Bundestag. Einer von denen, der heißt glaube ich irgendwie Kretschmer oder so. Der hat zwar eine konservative Meinung, aber der hat wenigstens Ahnung von dem, was er sagt.
Ja, hat ja seine Fraktion hinter sich. Das ist ja wohl nicht anzunehmen.
Da ist es so Usus, dass diejenigen, die jungen dabei sind, naja, die sollen sich erstmal einarbeiten. Die kriegen erstmal nichts zu sagen. Also da ist man dann mal so drauf, dass man sich freut, dass es dann mal Leute gibt, die von dem Thema, worüber sie reden, auch Ahnung haben. Aber dann haben die in der Fraktion nichts zu sagen, weil sie zu jungen dabei sind. Also daran scheitert es teilweise sogar. Also das ist irgendwie, ich muss sagen, ich bin in den letzten Monaten irgendwie mehr und mehr auf so eine Schiene gekommen, dass es mich einfach nur noch nervt, was so passiert.
Wie lange machst du denn schon politische Arbeit?
Oh man, das muss verdammt lange sein.
Ach mein Gott, ich bin 20, aber ich glaube, ich bin seit fünf Jahren bei den Julis und ich bin aktiv, ich glaube so 2006, 2007. Also aktiviert hat mich quasi der CCC deswegen. Ich habe irgendwie eure Kongresse von zu Hause aus verfolgt und habe damals noch TCPA und Facharbeiten drüber und Auswirkungen. Dieser ganze Gedöns hat mich dann auf diesen Netzpolitikbereich gebracht. Da bin ich dann dahin gekommen.
Da haben wir bei der Gelegenheit noch einen ziemlich coolen Tipp, denn wir veranstalten ja im Mai die SICKINT vom 22. und 24. Mai. Und ich glaube, die Netzsperren werden auch wieder Thema sein. Was Husi?
Ja, die Netzsperren werden ja Thema sein. Letztes Jahr hatten wir das ja eher so in Theorie. Und dieses Jahr machen wir das mal in der Praxis. Ich bringe so eine kleine Goldenshield Firewall mit und ein bisschen Equipment aus dem Iran. Und dann können wir das mal so richtig üben, wie das so geht. Wie das so in echt geht. Würdest du selber in China mit deinen Freunden zu Hause noch chatten können, irgendwie kannst du dann live ausprobieren. Das ist zumindest der Plan, aber das wird schon klappen. Ich bin ja guter Dinge.
Also es lohnt sich nach Köln zu fahren. Wer übrigens da mal klicken will, die URL, die ihr wissen wollt, ist sickint.ccc.de.
Das ist doch bestimmt doch alles im Wiki, oder? Im Wiki zur Sendung?
Was da jemand reinschreibt.
Ich weiß nicht, unser Moderator ist heute voll aufmüpfig, oder?
Tut mir total leid. Thomas, aber worauf ich noch mal hinaus wollte, ist, du machst das jetzt seit 4 Jahren. Wie viel Hoffnung hast du denn, also das klang jetzt ein bisschen an, auf Bundesebene ist schwierig, weil die jungen Leute kriegen halt nichts zu tun. Wie viel Hoffnung hast du denn generell, oder wie lange wird das dauern, bis Leute, die wenigstens Ahnung vom Netz haben, egal welche Meinung, bis die da in der Macht sind, oder sozusagen in die Strukturen kommen, wo sie was verändern können, oder wird das einfach nie mehr passieren?
Nein, nein, das wird passieren. Also das ist ganz klar. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt mal überlege mal, auch ein Herr Bosbach war mal jung.
Also das glaube ich nun nicht.
Jung war er, ob er jung im Kopf war, das wissen wir mal drüber. Aber vom körperlichen her... Der wird mal jung gewesen sein, gehe ich doch mal von aus. Also das heißt, man wächst da rein. Wir haben jetzt langsam die Zeit, dass diejenigen, die sich mit diesen Themen wirklich auskennen und selbst durch den Faktor, dass sie genervt von der aktuellen Politik sind, sich der Sache zuwenden. Zumindest aus unserer Fraktion, da kenne ich die Leute halt direkt, da weiß ich, das sind teilweise Leute, die kommen aus dem IT-Bereich, die haben dort jahrelang gearbeitet und die haben selber diese Kopfschmerzen gehabt, die wir gerade haben und sagen sich irgendwie, das kann doch nicht sein, dass alles an der Realität vorbei regiert wird. Und wir sitzen mittlerweile für uns im Bundestag. Also da bin ich schon mal relativ froh. Deswegen bin ich auch ganz froh, dass es diese Enquete-Kommission gibt, dass zumindest aus fast allen Parteien kompetente Leute da drin sind.
Okay, also wir werden jetzt gleich mal über die Enquete-Kommission sprechen. Das Wort ist jetzt einmal zu oft gefallen. Aber trotzdem mal die Frage. Es ist so nochmal auf das Druckzeugen, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Es ist ja so in der Politik, da hat man zumindest den Eindruck, es werden die jungen Leuten protegiert, die den alten Leuten in den Kram passen. Und da ist ja Netzverständnis sozusagen nicht wirklich am Start mittlerweile. Meinst du nicht, es besteht die Gefahr, dass sozusagen das immer jetzt auch weiterhin die Leute, also in den Strukturen nach oben wandern, die halt sagen, diese konservative Einstellung zum Netz haben?
Also ich bin da ziemlich optimistisch, muss ich sagen. Weil zumindest in allen Parteien außer, ja ich sehe es zumindest in der CDU noch nicht aktiv, gibt es ja relativ starke Bewegungen, sich dieser Netzpolitik zu öffnen. Ganz egal jetzt in welchem Format und in welcher Breitbandigkeit das Ganze dann am Ende des Tages doch stattfindet, aber zumindest in allen anderen Parteien sieht man, dass es sich öffnet. Und da werden auch die langfristig nicht drumherum kommen, sich dahin gehen zu öffnen, um diesen Leuten irgendwie endlich mal Gehör zu geben.
Wie lange werden wir noch warten müssen? Letzte Frage.
Ach, wir warten nicht mehr, Markus.
Also, die sitzen schon im Bundestag. Die müssten nur noch...
Nee, sag einfach sozusagen, mir den Daumen gepeilt, in deine Glaskugel geguckt, eine Zahl.
Ende dieser Legislaturperiode, drei Jahre.
Alles klar. Dann haben wir Politiker, die vom Netz Ahnung haben und auch was sagen dürfen. Thomas, vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich wäre jetzt also tatsächlich dafür, wenn jetzt nicht irgendwie die große Rebellion kommt, dass wir mal über diese komische Enquete... Wie heißt das richtig?
Die Enquete-Commission.
Weil es geht ja im Prinzip heute bei den drei Sachen, die wir besprechen, darum, wie geht Politik mit dem Netz um. Und das Positivste, was ich über diese Enquete-Position gehört habe, ist, dass es so eine Art Ausbildungslager für Politiker ist, damit sie irgendwie einen Format Plan haben. Jetzt... Oh Gott, muss ich mir überlegen. Wenn ich dich das überlege, kannst du... Constanze, du bist ja irgendwie mit dabei. Hat man gehört. Was ist das jetzt eigentlich?
Eine Enquete-Commission ist eigentlich eine Art Untersuchungskommission. Sie sollte sich also einem bestimmten Thema widmen und dazu über viele oder einige Monate, in diesem Fall sind es genau zwei Jahre, sich Meinung zu bestimmten vorher im Antrag festgelegten Themen bilden und das Ende dieser Enquete-Kommission bildet einen sogenannten Abschlussbericht. Das heißt, in diesem Fall besteht sie aus 37 Abgeordneten des Bundes und 37 technischen Sachverständigen in diesem Fall. Nicht alle technische Sachverständige, aber Sachverständige. Das heißt also, dass die paritätisch besetzt ist. Die fünf Fraktionen im Bundestag stellen also gemäß ihrer Zahlen im Bundestag dort diese 17 Abgeordneten und jeweils einer hat eine Sachverständigin. Ich bin einer von diesen. Und ungefähr die Hälfte der 17 Sachverständigen ist bis heute benannt worden. Einige Fraktionen haben sich da noch nicht eräußert. Aber es wird so sein, dass schon jetzt am Anfang April in der nächsten Sitzungswoche wird sich diese Enquete-Kommission konstituieren.
Und dann passiert die zwei Jahre was?
Man trifft sich dort meistens in der großen Runde, alle Vierteljahre. Aber es gibt auch noch Unterausschüsse. Und man wird die Themen, die vorher festgelegt sind, debattieren. Und das soll auch öffentlich sein. Das wird uns natürlich sehr freut.
Gibt es denn schon die Themen?
Ja klar, der Antrag ist auch ein letzter. Da kann man sich mal angucken. Es ist eine lange Liste. Es geht natürlich auch um geistige Eigentum. Es geht auch um Medienkompetenz. Also schon die Fragen, die wir hier besprochen haben. Es geht aber auch um sowas wie Green IT, E-Participation. Also schon netzpolitische Themen, die wir schon lange debattieren, aber im Fokus des Bundestags jetzt nicht eben standen.
Und was kommt da hinten raus?
Das Ende ist von so einer Enquete-Kommission. Das ist in der Regel ein Abschlussbericht. Wir hatten schon sehr interessante Enquete-Kommissionen. Das ist sehr häufig, etwa zur Frage der Ethik. Da ging es um Stammzellen und sowas. Es gibt auch in den Ländern eine Enquete-Kommission. Das ist schon nicht so häufig, dass sich der Bundestag zur Untersuchung eines bestimmten Themas so eine fraktionsübergreifende Kommission gibt.
Wen das interessiert, auf der deutschen Wikipedia gibt es da ausnahmsweise eine lange Liste mit all den Enquete-Kommissionen, die es in der Bundesrepublik noch gab. Wurde aus Relevanzgründen noch nicht gelöscht.
Also beeilt euch lieber.
Es ist natürlich so, dass die Fraktionen diese Enquete unterschiedlich sehen. Manche betrachten die als Alibi-Funktion. Wir wollen auch wirklich Interesse an dem Ergebnis zeigen. Aber nicht alle Fraktionen.
Am Ende wird halt ein Bericht stehen, und dieser Bericht soll der Regierung irgendwie Handlungsgrundlagen oder Empfehlungen geben, wie mit den einzelnen Themen umzugehen ist.
Und zwar möglichst mit Blick in die Zukunft, wenn man es mal so sagen will.
Aber die Geister scheiden sich halt noch an der Frage, ob das nur ein Knochen ist, den die Netzgemeinde jetzt hingeschmissen kriegt nach diesem ganzen Zensursula-Aufstand. Und das nur dazu da ist, um uns ruhig zu stellen, um uns das Gefühl zu geben, wir sind hier irgendwie ein bisschen vertreten. Die kümmern sich jetzt darum, die hören uns schon mal zu. Oder ob da wirklich was Sinnvolles bei rauskommt. Und naja, FIFA hat heute irgendwie gesagt, da ist so viel Sachverstand in der Kommission, das können die eigentlich gar nicht ernst meinen, dass sie das wirklich irgendwie sich daran halten, was dabei rauskommen könnte. Aber das müssen wir einfach mal abwarten.
Also am Ende ist es halt egal, wie die Parteien diese Ankerkommission sehen, wird es halt eine Eigendynamik entwickeln, eben weil das Netz halt da mit der Politik sehr unnütelbar konfrontiert ist und sehr unnütelbar zuguckt. Das heißt, es wird da eben die Netzöffentlichkeit halt dabei sein. Und das heißt, die Themen, die da jeweils diskutiert werden, werden dann halt eben im Netz auch weiter diskutiert. Und das ist halt der interessante Punkt, dass die jeweils diese Enquete-Sitzung dann Kondensationspunkte für die Diskussion um Themen sein werden, mit denen wir uns in der nächsten Zukunft halt irgendwie noch sehr intensiv auseinandersetzen müssen. Und selbst wenn die Enquete-Kommission an sich keinerlei Output hat, der irgendwie verwertbar ist, außer halt auf welche Berichte, ist es halt schon so, dass es für die Politik ein sehr wesentliches Signal ist, wie reagiert denn die Öffentlichkeit auf die Themen, die da gerade in der Enquete angesprochen werden.
Da sind sie von anderen Enquete nicht gewohnt, dass die Sitzung da so derart debattiert werden. Das wird aber hier so sein und wir haben auch als Sachverständige, die die schon bandant sind, auch beschlossen, dass wir über die Fraktionen hinweg auch zusammenarbeiten wollen. Also wir werden uns da nicht irgendwie so einer uninteressanten Parteitaktik hingeben. Uns geht es um die Sache.
Zur Verständnis, die Sachverständigen werden auch jeweils von den Parteien ernannt. Also quasi, man könnte im Prinzip jedem Sachverständigen eine Partei zuordnen.
Also bei mir persönlich ist es die Linksfraktion. Die hat zwei Abgeordneten. Und wir haben uns eigentlich mit allen Fraktionen des Bundestages, also wir jetzt als Chaos Computer Club unterhalten, und uns dann entschieden, das mit der Linkspartei zu machen. Aber es ändert sich absolut nichts daran, was wir da sachlich sagen werden.
Also sagen, und die Sieben, also beziehungsweise die Experten jetzt schon feststellen, die haben auf jeden Fall schon besprochen, dass ihr sozusagen euch nicht von der, welche Partei euch da berufen hat, sondern einfach sagen als Sachverständige dort.
Ja, also es wird da keine Beeinflussung auf parteipolitischer Ebene geben, sondern wir sind da als Sachverständige geraten, wenn wir unsere Sachverständigen Meinung abgeben.
Also spezifisch für die Sachverständigen, die halt eben aus der Netzgemeinde kommen, wäre es für die Parteien auch ziemlich blöd, wenn sie versuchen würden, die zu beeinflussen, weil das würde 30 Sekunden später auf dem Treter stehen und dann wäre sozusagen der Effekt halt hinüber. Also es ist halt so, dass da schon die Chance besteht, dass die Sachverständigen relativ unabhängig agieren können. Wie gesagt, inwieweit es halt irgendwie tatsächlich konkrete Ergebnisse gibt, da habe ich auch mal eine Zweifel, aber ich denke eben, dass die wesentliche Chance besteht halt darin, mal Flocke einzuschlagen und zu sagen, okay, hier haben wir den konzentrierten Sachverstand zu einem Thema abgefragt. Die Angriffskommission kann zum Beispiel auch Studien beauftragen, also sagen, okay, wir würden gerne mal zu diesem und jedem Thema mal gerne ein paar Zahlen haben.
Wir nehmen mal etwa die seltsamen Zahlen, die zum Firesharing so unterwegs sind. Also man könnte sich ja auch mal einen Überblick verschaffen und ein bisschen Versachlichung der Debatte. Und wir an CCC haben uns vorgenommen, die Enquete so zu benutzen, dass wir Konzepte, die wir haben, an die wir glauben, wo wir glauben, dass die einfach zukunftsträchtig sind, auch echt einbringen. Das werden wir auch tun, insbesondere zu Fragen des geistigen Eigentums.
Wie ist denn jetzt, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, so eine Art Ausbildungslager für Politiker, die Politiker, die da berufen wurden, ist es denn so, dass ihr, wenn ihr euch da zum ersten Mal zusammensetzt, dann gleich anfangen könnt zu reden oder muss dann erstmal sozusagen so eine Art Nachhilfeunterricht und Aufklärung betrieben werden?
Es ist natürlich klar, auf wen du anspielst. Der Vorsitzende dieser Enquete-Kommission ist Axel E. Fischer von der Union. Ja, wir haben den Hinweis schon verstanden. Und da ist es natürlich so, dass der sich in der letzten Woche unglaublich blamiert hat bei einem Interview im Deutschlandradio, der Deutschlandfunk war, glaube ich, breitband.
Das ist auch der, der keine Zeit fürs Internet hat, oder?
Ja, genau. Also da ist natürlich schon so, dass der Journalist ihnen einfach ein paar inhaltliche Fragen gestellt hat. Er ist der Vorsitzende dieser Kommission und er hat sich da sehr, ich muss mal sagen, blamiert. Denn er hat offenbar nicht mal die Fragen verstanden und hat dann aber auch nicht zugegeben, dass er von Begriffen wie Open Data, Liquid, Democracy überhaupt keine Idee hat, was das sein kann. Und hat sich damit so ein Politiker-Phrasen-Gedöns rausgerillt. Also ich muss schon sagen, selten wurde ein Politiker in Deutschland so vorgeführt. Das ist natürlich kein guter Beginn für die Enquete-Kommission.
Aber ich glaube, er selber hat es gar nicht gemerkt.
Natürlich hat er das gemerkt. Also ich denke, er wird schon einen Medienreferenten haben, der ihm gesagt hat, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen peinlich war.
Vielleicht hat es mir sein Berater hinterher gesagt. Das wäre ja auch schon mal was. Aber was ist denn sagen, okay, das ist Worst-Case-Szenario und gleich sehe ich noch den Vorsitzenden. Das ist ziemlich praktisch. Wie sieht es denn mit dem Rest aus?
Naja, wir kennen natürlich mittlerweile alle Abgeordneten, die sind bereits benannt. Das ist, muss ich sagen, schon sehr erfreulich, gerade von den Oppositionsparteien, dass da eben auch Leute drin sind, die sich wirklich für Netzpolitik interessieren. Also ich habe da jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass von den kleinen Parteien insbesondere, dass da jetzt irgendwie Leute benannt wurden, die man nur gar nicht akzeptieren könnte. Natürlich gibt es ein Problem, insbesondere bei den Sozialdemokraten, Herr Dörrmann, der sich ja gerade bei den Netzsperren auch nicht gerade mit, naja wie soll man sagen, bekleckert hat mit Fachwissen. Also der Dörrmann ist natürlich für die Internetspolitische Community einfach ein roter Tuch.
Weil der ja bei den Netzperren damals sozusagen mitgeholfen hat.
Natürlich, der hat auch eine Rhetorik gefahren, die diffamierend war teilweise. Also da ist natürlich ein Problem, dass die SPD ihn benannt hat.
Ich schätze mal, das spiegelt sich dann halt auch genau wie in den anderen Fraktionen, da schon so ein bisschen die Balance zwischen denen, die es verstanden haben und der Hausmeisterfraktion, die halt irgendwie...
Man muss sehen, die SPD hat sich unmittelbar nach der Wahl von ihren eigenen Entscheidungen zum Zugangserschwerungsgesetz abgesetzt. Die SPD sagt, nein, wir wollen dieses Zugangserschwerungsgesetz nicht mehr, unmittelbar nach der Wahl. Aber sie haben denjenigen, der es am meisten protegiert hat, nämlich den Herrn Dörrmann, dennoch in diese Kommission benannt für Netzpolitik. Eigentlich ist das unerhört. Ich meine, es ist eigentlich sowieso ein sehr merkwürdiger Vorgang, den man in unserer bundesrepublikanischen Geschichte suchen darf. In meiner Meinung nach ist das nicht ein einziges Mal passiert, nämlich dass die ganz große Mehrheit ein Gesetz beschlossen hat, ein Zugangserschwerungsgesetz und dass unmittelbar nach der Wahl beide Parteien sagen, war nicht so eine gute Idee. Die SPD hat sich total abgesetzt. Unser damaliger Innenminister Schäuble hat gesagt, na, war ein bisschen Wahlkampf, haben wir nicht so gemeint. Das ist schon unglaublich peinlich, dass sie also zugeben, was das für ein Unverfolgerung ist.
Bei uns war es nicht nur ein bisschen Wahlkampf, er hat gesagt, es war eigentlich nur für den Wahlkampf, um die CDU von anderen Parteien abzusetzen und es gab handwerkliche Fehler.
Da muss man schon sagen, da kann man den Glauben an die parlamentarische Demokratie schon verlieren, wenn die also selber eingestehen, was sie da von technischem Unverstand haben.
Da würde ich gerne noch mal eure Meinung zu einem kleinen Punkt haben. Es war ja so, dass zum Schluss irgendwie alle gesagt haben, also Netzperngesetz, ja nicht so eine geile Idee, aber Bundespräsident unterschreibt mal bitte trotzdem. Warum ist das passiert?
Es ist eine Frage der Gesichtswahrung am Ende. Sie haben ja auf die inhaltlichen Fragen des Bundespräsidialamts nicht geantwortet. Es ging ja vor allen Dingen in den Fragen, die der Bundespräsident gestellt hat an das Parlament, auch nochmal darum, ob es wirklich verfassungsgemäß war. Da gibt es ja eine Menge Fragen, geostische Fragen. Und es ist so, dass die einfach gar nicht geantwortet haben auf diese Frage. Sie mussten diese unangenehme, wie haben wir sie genannt, Gesetzesleiche, sie mussten ja irgendetwas machen, sie mussten in Kraft treten. Also es hat passiert und dann hat sich das Bundesinnenministerium entschieden, diesen Nichtanwendungserlass zu machen. Das heißt, ein, zwei Tage später wurde beschlossen, es wird nicht angewandt. Und geht natürlich den Willen des Parlamentes. Aber es gibt gerade keine Partei im Bundestag.
Okay, sagen wir nochmal, nur zu meinem Verständnis auch. Also es gibt jetzt ein Gesetz, das hat unsere Legislative, also die gesetzgebende, Mit großer Mehrheit? Der gesetzgebende Teil des Staates sozusagen beschlossen. Das ist vom Bundespräsident entschieden.
Ausgefertigt?
Das heißt. Unterschrieben worden. So und jetzt hat eine ausführende Behörde, das ist dann die Exekutive, wenn ich im Gemeinschaftskundeunterricht richtig aufgehört habe, hat gesagt so, nee, machen wir aber nicht. Jetzt ist es so, wir sind jetzt nicht so richtig böse wahrscheinlich, weil das Gesetz passt uns den Kram, aber hä?
Es findet sich vor allen Dingen auch keine Oppositionspartei, die jetzt gegen diesen Nichtanwendungserlass vorgehen würde.
Obwohl das verfassungsrechtlich fast noch bedenklicher ist.
Ja, denn niemand will jetzt sagen, hey, ja, wir wollen doch, dass es angewendet wird. Und wir haben dann ein Problem erkannt, was uns in dieser Konstellation noch nie begegnet ist. Nämlich die Frage der Verfassungsbeschwerde. Dieses Gesetz ist ja in Kraft und im Prinzip könnten sich jetzt verschiedene Initiativen, die die Verfassungsbeschwerden dagegen ja auch bereits vorbereiten, nach Karlsruhe wenden. Das können sie aber nicht, denn der Nichtanwendungserlass hat genau diese Frist, die man haben kann, wenn man in Karlsruhe Beschwerde einlegt. Also ein Jahr.
Du hast ein Jahr Zeit, um in Karlsruhe zu klagen, aber du kannst nur klagen oder Beschwerde einlegen. Du kannst aber das nur machen, wenn das Gesetz in Kraft ist. Ausgefertigt, das ist es inzwischen. Aber es muss auch angewendet werden. Und das wird es nicht für das nächste Jahr. Und deswegen kann sich das auch noch...
Du brauchst einen konkreten Betroffenen. Das heißt, du musst in der Verfassungsbeschwerde genau beschreiben, welche oder welcher, können eine oder mehrere Personen sein, direkt von so einem Gesetz betroffen sind. Das kann natürlich nicht passieren, solange es nicht angewendet wird. Das heißt, hier hat sich die BMI auch gleich noch hintenrum eine Methode ausgesagt, um wirkungsvoll eine Verfassungsbeschwerde, die mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit recht peinlich ausgeht, für die Regierung auszuheben. Ich denke, da müssen wir auch nochmal mit Juristen reden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das hört sich jetzt so nach einer Art Loch an.
Das ist ein Hack, würde ich sagen. Das ist ein Hack.
Okay, das heißt, ihr seid gerade von der Regierung geowned?
Ne, die Regierung hat ihr parlamentarisches System geowned.
Das BMI gehört ja zur Regierung, wenn man so rumzählen will.
Naja, aber wir haben trotzdem den Punkt, dass möglicherweise in einem Jahr ein Gesetz in Kraft wird und dann nicht mehr Verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt werden kann, weil, also das heißt, es ist ja dann...
Wenn man es sich so klassisch vorstellen will, dann läuft da halt so ein Zombie durch den Reißdach.
Naja, der Punkt ist natürlich auch dran, das muss man sich mal ein bisschen überlegen. Die Zeit dieses Nichtanwendungserlasses soll ja auch genutzt werden für eine gewisse Evaluation. Die findet auch derzeit schon statt. BKA weist etwa schon Zahlen vor für Januar und Februar. Also wo waren Seiten, die gemeldet wurden, konnten die gelöscht werden und so weiter. Aber natürlich können sie nicht tatsächlich evaluieren, wie eine Sperrliste gewirkt hat. Denn es gibt ja keine Sperrliste. Also die ganze Evaluierung hat natürlich diesen Pferdefuß, dass nur ein ganz kleiner Teil dieses Gesetzes evaluiert werden kann, nämlich die Frage, was gelöscht werden kann. Und im Übrigen...
Also ganz ehrlich, ich habe jetzt den Faden verloren. Also weil der Punkt ist, ich habe den Eindruck, man macht so eine politische Entscheidung einfach beliebig kompliziert und irgendwann haben die Leute dann keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht kompliziert.
Na gut, aber das Kernprinzip hast du schon ganz klar erkannt. Also es ist halt so, dass Hex-Überkomplexität sind in der Politik immer üblicher und je finsterer so ein Skandal ist, desto komplexer muss man ihn machen.
Damit niemand mehr mitkriegt, um was es eigentlich geht.
Ich würde sagen, wir führen das nach den Nachrichten weiter. Vorher wollte ich noch eine ganz einfachen Frage widmen, die wir heute in der Sendung gestellt haben. Das ist nämlich die Frage Jungen-Media-Schutz-Stars-Vertrag. Da geht es ja darum, dass man Inhalte labelt, sagt ab 18. Das heißt, es dürfte dann erst ab 22 Uhr im Internet gesendet werden. Unsere Frage war, wie spät ist es eigentlich im Internet? Robert hat vielleicht eine Antwort. Hallo Robert.
Hi, wie spät ist es im Internet?
Schöne Sendung, übrigens wollte ich sagen. Und ich bin auch ein großer Fan von Erich Kessner. Da sollte ich noch loswerden.
Sind wir das nicht alle?
Wie spät ist es im Internet?
Wie spät ist es im Internet? Also ich würde sagen, für jede Kommunikation gibt es ja eine Absenderadresse. Und ich sage mal, eine Werbung mit dieser Absenderadresse funktioniert ja mittlerweile auch sehr gut. Gerade was Social Networks angeht, da wird ja mal Werbung eingeblendet über den Ursprungsort des Absenders. Im Grunde genommen könnte eine Webseite auf diesen Verfahren aufbauen und genauso prüfen, wie spät ist es bei dieser Absenderadresse im Grunde genommen. Und das Einzige, was denen noch entgegensprechen würde, wäre diese Benutzung von anonymes Proxys oder hier von der TU.
Ich wollte dich gerade fragen. Also ich surf normalerweise nicht mit einer deutschen IP-Adresse. Keine Ahnung, wie das bei dir ist.
Okay, ich bin da noch sehr ehrlich unterwegs, muss ich sagen.
Ich hätte gerne jetzt eine Frage an die Fachleute. Wie lange dauert es, mir ein Programm zu schreiben, das meine IP ständig in eine Geolocation wechselt, wo es immer 22.03 Uhr ist?
Da brauchst du doch kein Programm für.
Das ist ziemlich trivial.
Aber ich sag mal, das ist nicht trivial, aber im Grunde genommen wäre die Möglichkeit, solche Anonymus-Proxys abzugrenzen oder auszugrenzen, oder deren Benutzung einfach zu unterbinden, die Möglichkeit, solche zeitlichen Beschränkungen einzuführen.
Na ja, also ich meine, wenn du erst mal alles so eingrenzen und begrenzen kannst, praktisch so eine chinesische Internetmauer hast, dann brauchst du auch keine Sendezeitbegrenzung mehr. Weil dann hast du ganz andere Möglichkeiten, da Dinge zu begrenzen.
Okay gut, das sind die Rollstuhlfahnen und Politiker, die jetzt in andere Forts abgewandert sind, die das Ganze ins Rollen gebracht haben. Ich sag mal, das geht natürlich nur, wenn man es auch weiterdenkt. Ich bin ja auf eurer Seite, aber rein theoretisch ist das ja durchaus möglich. Und wenn man schon über solche Sperren redet, dann redet man wahrscheinlich auch über anonyme Benutzung, die ja dann wahrscheinlich eh fallen wird im Laufe dieser Zeit.
Ich finde es interessant, die Frage, also ich hatte nur die Gelegenheit, die Frage mit dem neuen Innenminister Thomas de Maizière zu debattieren. Also ob es überhaupt eine Frage, oder ob es überhaupt ein Recht auf Anonymität im Netz noch gibt.
Ja, also ich sag mal, man beschränkt in alle Richtungen. Also im Grunde genommen wäre es nur konsequent, diese Anonymität auch aufzuheben. Und das erste wäre natürlich, solche anonymen Proxies zu verbieten. Um Gottes Willen, ich hasse diese Netzsperrengeschichte. Ich bin wie gesagt großer Fan von Erich Kessner. Und der Treffner hätte man das nicht formulieren können. Im Grunde genommen geht es um Aufklärung und nicht um Vertuschungen. Also meine Meinung.
Glaubst du, dass die Debatte um darum eigentlich irgendwas genützt hat, für die Frage der Bilder und Filme von Kindesmissbrauch? Also wie siehst du überhaupt so diese Debatte, in Bezug auf das Problem, was eigentlich gelöst werden sollte?
Das ist eine Frage, der in Beantwortung, wie ich sicher weiß, mehrere Minuten dauern wird. Das wiederum bedeutet, Robert muss jetzt noch so lange gedulden, bis Nachrichtenwörter und Verkehr vorbei sind, weil dann machen wir damit weiter. Nachrichten. Mit Mario Bartsch.
Zu den Terroranschlägen von Moskau haben sich islamistische Rebellen aus dem Nordkaukasus bekannt. Ihr Anführer erklärte in einem Internet-Video, die Anschläge seien ein Racheakt dafür, dass russische Sicherheitskräfte Zivilisten getötet hätten. Der Rebellenführer kündigte weitere Anschläge an. Zwei Selbstmordattentäterinnen hatten in der Moskau Metro am Montag 39 Menschen mit in den Tod gerissen. Bei zwei weiteren Selbstmordanschlägen wurden heute mindestens 12 Menschen in der südrussischen Provinz Dagestan getötet. Die internationale Staatengemeinschaft stellt Haiti für den Wiederaufbau nach dem Erdbeben vor zweieinhalb Monaten mehrere Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Geberkonferenz der Vereinten Nationen in New York. Das meiste Geld versprach Venezuela mit umgerechnet 1, 6 Milliarden Euro. Große Geldsummen sagten auch die EU und die USA zu. Bei dem Beben waren in Haiti rund 230.000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen und Hunderttausende obdachlos geworden. Zur Enttäuschung von Umweltschützern hat US-Präsident Obama Teile der US-Küste für Öl- und Gasbohrungen freigegeben. Sie seien notwendig, um den amerikanischen Energiebedarf zu decken und Arbeitsplätze zu sichern, sagte Obama. Er wolle auch alternativere Energien weiter fördern. Betroffen sind die Ostküste am Atlantik und die Südküste am Golf von Mexiko. Im Basketball-Eurocup hat Alba Berlin als erste deutsche Mannschaft überhaupt die Final-Vorrunde erreicht. Die Berliner besiegten im Viertelfinal-Rückspiel Jerusalem mit 72 zu 59 und machten damit die 61 zu 67 Niederlage aus dem Hinspielbett. Heute Nacht gibt es ein paar Wolken, aber meist bleibt es trocken. Die Tieftemperaturen liegen um 1 Grad. Am Tag dann maximal 12 Grad. Zunächst ist das längere Zeit heiter. Später gibt es häufiger Wolken und vor allem in Richtung Prägnitz und Hafenland auch Regen oder Graupelschauer. A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Ciesa und Thesen liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Da handelt es hier wohl um Reifenteilefahrt entsprechend vorsichtig. A9 Berlin Richtung Halle Leipzig. Zwischen Belitz-Hallstetten und Belitz gibt es Bergungsarbeiten nach einem Unfall. Die rechte Spur ist da gesperrt, benutzt die linke Spur. A10 westlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieckhafenland. Zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau gibt es auch eine Sperrung. Und zwar der Richtungsfahrbahn wegen Bergungsarbeiten nach einem Unfall. A11 Pumeln Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Joachimsthal und Korinne gab es einen Unfall. Dort ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Und A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt Oder. Zwischen Storkow und Fürstenwalde West gab es einen Unfall mit einem Lkw. Dort ist die rechte Spur blockiert. Sonst überall gute Fernsehen.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2?
Chaos Radio, mit konstant so kurzen Scusi und wohin verschwindet Frank Rieger eigentlich immer während der Nachrichten?
Zum Kaffeeautomaten.
Äh, koffeinsüchtig, so sind sie. Die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club, die hier jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat reinkommen und über Techniksachen, so im weitesten Sinne könnte man sagen, mit euch und uns reden.
Das machen wir jetzt in einer Beschreibung, oder? Was macht ihr im Chaos Radio Techniksachen?
Ja, also ich mein, ist aber sozusagen das Wort, was tatsächlich alle Leute verstehen. Was macht ihr da im Radio? Ja, so Technik.
Der Kaffee ist gex, der Frank ist wieder da.
Hey, welcome back! So, es geht heute um Netzsperren. Um ACTA. Ein Geheimvertrag. James Bond ist ja ein Geheimvertrag, der dazu dienen soll, dass man eure iPods durchsuchen kann, wenn ihr fliegt. Und um einen Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag, der dafür sorgen soll, dass das Internet ganz sauber wird. Und wir haben gerade mit Robert gesprochen, welcome back auch. Und Konz hat eine Frage an dich.
Ach, eigentlich ist mir jetzt eine andere eingefallen.
Immer her damit.
Kann ich die vielleicht trotzdem mal stellen? Wir hatten ja vorhin irgendwie diese Debatte. Was steht eigentlich dahinter? Was ist die große Idee hinter dieser Säuberungsaktion und dieser Internetregulierung? Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung dazu?
Also ich sag mal so, ich denke schon, und das kommt eben aus der Rollstuhlzeit, ich denke mal schon, dass es einfach um die totale Kontrolle geht. Letztendlich ist alles, was der Staat an Daten bekommt, für ihn irgendwo wertvoll bezüglich irgendwelcher Raster, die er fahndet oder bezüglich irgendwelcher Auswertungen, wo ist noch mehr Geld rauszuholen, wo gibt es Steuersünder, die ich auf diesem Wege vielleicht erwische. Also ich denke mal, es geht dem Staat einfach um totale Kontrolle. Und um nichts weiter. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass... Also ich sag mal, die Effizienz dieser Maßnahmen ist, glaube ich, die tendiert gegen Null, weil Kriminalität sucht sich immer ihre Wege. Und letztendlich weicht die einfach nur aus. Also ich sag mal, da gibt es keinen Druck, sondern es gibt einfach nur ein Ausweichen. Und das sucht neue Wege. Und deswegen kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es darum alleine geht. Sondern ich denke mal eher, dass es um die totale Kontrolle geht.
Also das heißt, wir haben ja jetzt eigentlich mit den Netzsperren eine andere Debatte, als bei dieser angeblichen Sicherheit, die uns andere Sätze versprechen. Es geht ja darum, dass du was nicht sehen darfst. Es geht dir darum, quasi so eine Art sauber Internet für die erste Welt zu etablieren. Oder vielleicht noch die erste Welt und Teile der Entwicklungssender noch dazu. Wenn man jetzt mal ACTA dazu nimmt, dann ist es ja eine größere Gruppe.
Also ich sag mal so, die Netzschwere ist vielleicht nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Im Grunde genommen, wenn ihr, und ich hab der Sendung ein bisschen zuhören können, wenn man über ACTA redet, dann geht das ja viel mehr in die Tiefe, sag ich mal. Und im Endeffekt ist das wahrscheinlich, also ich sag mal, die Netzschwere ist eher populistisch. Und der Rest ist wahrscheinlich eher das Kontrollorgan, was da hinter geschlossenen Vorhängen verhandelt.
Also bei ACTA würde ich aber sagen, dass es hauptsächlich um irgendwie Gewinne geht. Da geht es um Geld, da geht es um richtig dick Geld.
Nee, es geht immer um Geld. Also ich mein, hey, da kannst du immer das Argument bringen.
Also ich denke, dass der Hintergrund schon ist, dass es da um eine Disziplinierung geht. Also sowohl was die Inhalte angeht, als auch was den Umgang mit geistigen Eigentum und ähnlichen Dingen angeht. Dass den alten Herren, die uns da momentan noch regieren, die wollen zwar gern, dass wir die Chancen des Internets, also diese ganze bunte Geschichte damit handeln und so. Das wird das alles nutzen, aber auf der einen Seite uns natürlich irgendwie gegen die Chinesen abgrenzen können, sowohl sicherheitsmäßig als auch was irgendwie die Sicherheit des geistigen Eigentums angeht, als auch dafür sorgen, dass in den kommenden Krisen das Internet ihnen nicht der Kontrolle entleitet. Und die momentane Struktur, die da ist, wird da in diesen Kreisen als irgendwie nicht krisenfähig angesehen. Und das ist denke ich mal der Hintergrund dessen von all diesen Maßnahmen, dass sie sich da allmählich so ein Set von Dingen zusammenbauen, mit denen sie glauben, die Kontrolle behalten zu können, wenn es hier mal ein bisschen weniger lustig wird.
Richtig, ja. Klingt plausibel auf jeden Fall, keine Frage. Ich denke nur, wenn man sich solche technischen Möglichkeiten etabliert, bleibt es bei dieser Nutzung oder geht es einfach weiter? Also ich sage mal, das ist genau die gleiche Geschichte mit den Mautstellen. Ich habe damals schon überlegt, warum nicht auch den Fahrer fotografieren? Warum fotografiert man nur das Kennzeichen? Im Grunde genommen fotografiert man mit Sicherheit auch den Fahrer. Dann macht man eine Gesichtsfelderkennung und schon hat man noch perfektere Bewegungsdaten als vielleicht mit einer triangulären Ortung über das Handy, was er da mit sich führt.
Zumindest im deutschen Mautsystem werden die Fahrer üblicherweise mitfotografiert.
Richtig, genau. Aber Baden-Württemberg war glaube ich das erste Land, das das mal öffentlich gemacht hat. Ich meine, es gab da mal eine Diskussion, dass es eben nicht gemacht wird.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Nutzung der Möglichkeiten.
Der verweist es gut. Wie war es denn bisher mit neuen Technologien und Möglichkeiten? Und wie wurden sie bisher genutzt? Und bisher wurden sie meistens dann ausgebaut, nachträglich. Und es wurde hinterher irgendwie Dinge auch anders genutzt als sie.
Wir haben natürlich auch schon gesehen, wer der Interesse hat. Wir haben eine Debatte gehabt über unerlaubte Glücksspiele. Natürlich über die Fragen von urheberrechtlich geschützten Werken. Wir haben über Nazi-Seiten, also alles das kam ja im Wahlkampf schon hoch.
Ein gutes Beispiel, um da nochmal zurückzukommen, das geht jetzt auch wieder zurück auf die Netzsperren, ein super Beispiel ist Italien. Italien hat 2006 angefangen, so genannte kinderpornografische Seiten zu sperren. Das gleiche Spiel, was Zensursula gebracht hat, das gleiche Spiel, was die Malmström jetzt bringt, das war in Italien 2006. Haben sie gesagt, nee, es geht wirklich nur um solche Sachen, wir grenzen das ein, das wird für nichts anderes benutzt, haben sie angefangen, ein paar hundert Seiten zu sperren. Dann, das nächste, was kam, war Glücksspiel. In Italien ist das ähnlich wie in Deutschland, staatliches Glücksspielmonopol. Also haben sie 536 Glücksspielseiten gesperrt. Das war 2008 oder so. Inzwischen gibt es halt Gerichtsurteile durch die, wie hast du gesagt Frank, Content-Mafia?
Die Musik- und Filmindustrie, ich darf mal noch mal was setzen hier.
Die über italienische Gerichte erreicht haben, dass The Pirate Bay auf diese Sperrfilter gesetzt wird. Und jetzt wird The Pirate Bay in Italien gesperrt. Malta leidet auch drunter, weil die Ablinks von Malta des Internet-Backbounds laufen über Italien. Das heißt, die Leute in Malta haben jetzt auch kein Pirate Bay mehr, obwohl die da gar nichts mit zu tun haben erstmal.
Da kommen wir noch mal zu einem wichtigen Punkt.
Das ist doch ein super Beispiel, wie es läuft. Es wird genauso laufen wie in Italien.
Das ist aber nur wirtschaftlich, sage ich mal. Was ich zum Beispiel bezüglich dieser SWIFT-Diskussion, Amerikaner wollen unsere Bankdaten haben.
Okay, Robert, vielen Dank, aber du tendierst dazu, sozusagen abzuweichen. Und wir haben noch den Martin in der Leitung. Der hat nämlich eine Frage zu den Netzfiltern. Und in diesem Fall, ich weiß nicht, ob man das sozusagen politisch zu sehen sollte, aber Netzfilter schlägt Zwift. Zumindest heute Abend. Aber vielen Dank. So, dann haben wir nämlich den Martin hier. Martin, hi.
Hallöchen, guten Abend.
Wo ist deine Frage zu den Netzfiltern?
Ja, unter anderem. Ja, ich hatte vorhin, ihr habt kurz von der Detektierbarkeit gesprochen, der Filter oder dieser Filterlisten. Das würde mich prinzipiell interessieren, wie das funktioniert, aber das müsst ihr vielleicht nicht in der Sendung klären, wenn ihr das im Nachhinein verlinken könnt oder so.
Nein, im Prinzip ist das ganz einfach. Ich erkläre es mal kurz für DNS-Sperren, für das, was Frau van der Leyen da so vorgeschlagen hat und das, was auch bei der Frau Malström anscheinend so im... Also die hat das ja nicht so definiert, aber... Also für DNS ist es ganz einfach. Wenn ich im Internet-Server und in meinem Browser eingebe www.ccc.de, dann geht mein Rechner daher zu einem DNS-Server, fragt den du www.ccc.de, was ist denn das für eine IP? Der DNS-Server gibt mir die IP zurück, mein Rechner macht eine Verbindung zu dieser IP auf Pod 80 auf, und ich sehe die Webseite.
Eigentlich einfach so weit so gut.
So weit so gut, so funktioniert das normalerweise. Wenn man jetzt DNS-Filterung macht, dann wird der DNS-Server vom Provider so manipuliert, dass er dir nicht mehr die Wahrheit sagt, sondern dich anlügt.
Und zwar haben sie dafür übrigens einen schönen Namen, nämlich Government Enhanced Response.
Also in China heißt das irgendwie, wie nennen sie das mit der Zensur in China?
Irgendeinen euphämistischen Namen, wenn sie schon haben, Great Wall?
Nein, sie harmonisieren das Internet. Also bei so einer DNS-Sperre läuft das dann so, dein Rechner fragt den DNS-Server www.ccc.de, welcher IP-Nummer ist das? Und der DNS sagt dir nicht mehr die echte IP-Nummer vom CCC, sondern sagt dir irgendeine andere IP-Nummer von einer Webseite, wo diese bekannte Stop-Seite draufliegt. Dein Rechner macht darauf hin, im Glauben zum CCC zu gehen, dorthin eine Verbindung auf und du siehst diese Stop-Seite. So funktioniert es. Und naja, wie man es detektiert, ist doch ganz einfach irgendwie. Du suchst ja zwei DNS-Server auf der Welt, einer, der vielleicht lügt und einer, der garantiert nicht lügt.
Wobei du einfach herausfinden kannst, welcher lügt, denn das sind ja definierte in Deutschland, die einen müssen.
Und dann testest du einfach www.ccc.de, fragst den einen, fragst den anderen. Man kennt ja das alte Sprichwort, Lügen haben kurze Beine. Das gilt auch im Internet. Du wirst ziemlich schnell herausfinden, welche DNS-Server dir welchen Quatsch erzählen und welche nicht. Und sie können dagegen nichts tun. Weil wenn sie aufhören, uns irgendwie die Filterlisten detektierbar zu machen, dann hören sie auf zu filtern. Also ich meine, deswegen haben Filterlisten, vor allem diese angeblich geheimen Filterlisten, den inherenten Schaden, dass sie den größten möglichen Gau, nämlich dass die Listen an interessierte Pädophile liegen, die dann so eine Art gelbe Seiten für umsonst auf Steuergelder erstellt bekommen haben, dass genau das nicht zu verhindern ist. Es ist inherent in dieser Technologie. Es geht gar nicht ohne. Und im Prinzip ist das für Hybridsperren und alles andere, was da diskutiert wird, genauso.
Hybrid was?
Hybridsperren.
Naja, wir sollten darüber mal sprechen, da das Innenministerium derzeit sagt, Hybridsperren wären vielleicht für ein neues Zugangserschwerungsgesetz eine Idee. Die wollte daran festhalten.
Ja, das macht es auch nicht unmöglich.
Was sind denn die Hybridsperren?
Also Hybridsperren funktionieren so, dass ich nicht mehr die DNS manipuliere, die DNS-Server, die dann mir eine falsche IP zurückgeben, sondern ich definiere erst mal, was ich sperren will. Also ich sage, ich will den CCC sperren, der hat eine IP-Nummer. Oder vielleicht auch ein ganzes.
So ein garartgeheimer Wunsch von dir?
Nee, nee, das gibt es wirklich. Das wird in England gemacht. Das Clean-Feed-Programm aus Großbritannien funktioniert genau nach diesem Prinzip. Das in Australien diskutierte Zensursystem funktioniert auch genau nach diesem Prinzip. Was man macht, ist, man erstellt erst mal eine Liste von IP-Nummern oder IP-Ranges, wo Sachen liegen, die man ausfiltern möchte, ohne die genau zu spezifizieren. Und dann tut man in einem ersten Schritt, allen Datenverkehr, der zu diesen IP-Ranges oder zu diesen IPs geht, über eine andere Route führen. Den führt man nicht daraus ins Internet, wo es normalerweise rausgeht, sondern den führt man auf eine Seitenstraße. Dort steht ein transparenter Proxy oder ein System, wo der Datenverkehr durchläuft. Und dieses System guckt sich den Datenverkehr ganz genau an. Und schaut dann, ah, du willst zu YouTube. Wohin willst du denn zu YouTube? Welches Video guckst du dir an? Ah, das Video, wo Kemal Atatürk beleidigt wird. Ne, das zeigen wir dir nicht. Und dieser zweite Schritt, das zeigen wir dir nicht. Das funktioniert dann in diesem System, was den Datenverkehr anguckt genau. Und dann ganz individuell auf einzelne Bilder oder auf einzelne Webseiten sagen kann, das darfst du nicht sehen.
Der Unterschied ist also...
Die können dann machen, dass du Spiegel.de noch lesen kannst, aber das Bild, was zu dem Artikel da steht, das siehst du nicht mehr.
Der Unterschied ist also genau der, der zwischen dem Gesetz bei uns und etwa der Lösung aus Australien und Großbritannien, die es Gusi eben nannte. Bei uns haben wir nur voll qualifizierte Domain-Namen. Das heißt, die gesamte Domain wird gesperrt oder nichts. Und hier ist es halt spezifischer, das führt aber auch dazu, dass das Overblocking, das sogenannte Overblocking, geringer wird. Dass man also nicht so sehr viel mit sperrt, weil es eben im selben Domain ist.
Sondern nur das sperrt, was quasi direkt auf der Liste steht.
Es ist viel aufwendiger, viel teurer, kann man genauso schnell und einfach umgehen. Man muss es ein bisschen anders machen, wie bei DNS, aber es geht genauso. Und es ist auch nicht viel schwieriger. Und was auch zu beachten ist, sämtlicher Verkehr von allen Leuten, die zum Beispiel zu YouTube surfen, wenn man bei dem Beispiel von eben bleiben, der hier Datenverkehr wird ganz genau analysiert. Da wird ganz genau erfasst, welches Video guckst du dir an, wie oft hast du draufgeklickt, hast du einen Kommentar hinterlassen, was stand in dem Kommentar drinnen. Und das betrifft alle Leute, die in einen Server oder wie zum Beispiel YouTube unsurfen, wo nur ein Film gesperrt wird. Aber alle Leute, die zu YouTube gehen, egal was sie sich angucken, werden durch den Filter durchlaufen und ihre Daten werden erfasst, ausgewertet und so weiter. Und so ein System ist natürlich der perfekte Einstieg zur Zensur. Und so machen also das Prinzip wird ja in China mitunter auch angewendet. Ja, du siehst dann die Ergebnisse und alles in den News. Aber sobald du auf die Seite klickst, ist der Artikel bei Spiegel über 1989 und Platz des himmlischen Friedens und so nicht mehr vorhanden.
Also was man damit machen kann, ist halt so granular, dass man damit zum Beispiel auch einzelne Google-Suchergebnisse rausfüttern kann aus Seiten. Also man kann halt da auch Pattern-Matching machen, das noch sehr viel genauer ist, bis runter zu einzelnen Kommentaren in Blogs oder ähnlichem. Das ist so die ungeahnte Möglichkeit. Die Zensur kann da, also wenn diese Technologie einmal installiert ist, kann die halt eben genau so granular funktionieren, dass sie halt auch sehr schwer zu bemerken ist. Das ist während es ja sonst so ist, wenn eine komplette Domain nicht erreichbar ist, wenn wir plötzlich YouTube nicht erreichen können, würden es die meisten Leute wohl doch irgendwie mitbekommen.
Wenn halt auf YouTube ein Video nicht mehr zu sehen und anzuklicken ist, dann merken das die meisten Leute nicht direkt. Alles andere scheint ja zu gehen.
Also ich finde es ganz interessant, dass wir jetzt wie selbstverständlich so ein bisschen auf China oder Iran als Beispiel für die, die ganz schlimm machen gekommen sind. Denn ich glaube der Punkt ist hier auch, dass wir uns da Fragen danach stellen müssen, wie unsere Demokratie funktioniert. Ja, was ist das Modell? Und zur Zeit ist dieses Streben so richtig, selbst bei Stab Richtung China, ja, wir regulieren das immer stärker. Natürlich weisen jetzt alle diesen Zensurvorwurf von sich, ja. Klar, weil auch niemand irgendwie bei diesen Bildern oder Filmen die Kindesmissbrauch zeigen, an Zensur denkt, das will ja niemand haben. Aber dass natürlich die...
Die selben technischen Möglichkeiten verwendet werden können, um ganz andere Sachen zu filtern, das ist das eigentliche Problem, worum es hier geht. Und deswegen darf man nie ein System installieren, was diesem technischen Möglichkeiten bietet. Zumindest nicht in einer demokratischen offenen Gesellschaft, für die sich Europa hält oder die sie sein möchte. Zumindest habe ich das so mitgekriegt.
Mit der Argumentation könnte man auch sagen, die Polizisten dürfen keine Schusswaffen mehr tragen, weil damit könnten sie auch Unschuldige erschießen.
Am Ende ist es ja eine Frage der Abwägung. Die Meinungsfreiheit bedeutet ja, dass du das Recht hast, etwas zu sagen, auch wenn es jemand anderes nicht passt. Und die Diskussion darüber, was wir an Inhalten als Gesellschaft nicht haben wollen, was wir als Gesellschaft, was wir gerade in Deutschland spezifisch, doch eher etwas unfallreicher historisch bedingt. Und die Mechanismen, wie diese sozusagen zustande kommt, dafür gibt es ja tatsächlich Gerichte und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Rechtsstaatliche Regeln, ja.
Also tatsächlich rechtsstaatliche Regeln. Und wenn wir uns als Gesellschaft darauf einigen, dass bestimmte Inhalte illegal sind, dann sollen sie bitte auch bestraft werden. Das heißt, dann soll die Verbreitung und Produktion dieser Inhalte bestraft werden.
Das heißt löschen auch.
Und halt auch ausfindig machen der Leute, die es tun. Und das ist der einzige Weg, der funktioniert. Wir können nicht sagen, wir als Gesellschaft einigen uns jetzt mal darauf, dass da irgendeine obskure Kommission hingeht, dass wir bestimmte Sachen nicht sehen sollen, wenn wir nicht wissen, wie man daran kommt. Das ist völlig unwürdig.
Ich meine, es soll trotzdem, wir wissen, dass technisch detektierbar ist, immer noch eine geheime Sperre zu sein. Das heißt, derjenige wird auch nicht informiert. Die Listen werden quasi an die großen Provider und natürlich auch noch an die Unis und andere große Institutionen weitergegeben, damit die umgesetzt werden für die Sperrinfrastruktur. Aber der Betroffene, der soll nicht mal informiert werden. Das ist irgendwie ein sehr merkwürdiges Konstrukt, das rechtsstaatliche Standards vermissen lässt.
Vielen Dank, Martin. Auf jeden Fall haben wir noch mal die Netzfilter von vorne nach hinten aufgerollt.
Oh, wir haben vergessen, dass noch Martin da war.
Kann ich noch mal ganz kurz?
Ich bin zum Beispiel ein Supporter beim Online-Game-Spiel. Ich will das Spiel nicht nennen, das ist egal. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel auch ein Problem mit den China-IPs und China-Leuten usw. Ich wollte jetzt nur noch mal Senf dazu geben und zwar diese China-Leute.
Was für China-Leute? Wo überredest du gerade von Computerspiel-Benutzern aus China? Und was für Probleme habt ihr da? Die Leute aus China kommen nie auf die Server, weil die große Firewall immer alles blockt? Dann sag doch mal kurz den Satz.
Einfach ganz einfaches Ding. Sie benutzen verschiedene Routen, sowohl über Niederlande, über Großbritannien, über sonst welche Länder.
Ich vermute, dass dein Problem nicht wirklich ganz in die Sendung gehört. Dazu kommt, dass du nicht genau beschreiben kannst, wie es aussieht. Und wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit, aber trotzdem vielen Dank für den Versuch. Dann haben wir noch Dominik.
Hi.
Du hattest noch mal eine Frage, wo ich dich erstmal fragen muss, ob dir so ein Thema passt. Jetzt geht es um Elena. Ist es auch Teil dieses?
Also ich bin neugierig.
Okay, stell mal deine Frage.
Ich wollte ein kurzes Update geben.
Ich war heute mit Meinart in Karlsruhe.
Dominik, du bist es. Hi.
Ja, hat er doch gesagt, der Dominik.
Okay, vier Leute verstehen Sie jetzt gerade blendend. Ich bin raus und vermutlich die ganzen, die ganzen, sagen Leute vom Radio auch. Was ist Elena? Wer ist Dominik? Was ist die News?
Dominik gehört zum Markerzensur und Dominik ist Jurist. Und Hacker im Geiste, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, ich meine.
Dominik war heute in Karlsruhe und hat die 22.000 Vollmachten für die Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen Elena beim Bundesverfassungsgericht eingekippt. Dazu kommen wir jetzt. Elena ist dieses Arbeitnehmervorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz, wo von allen Leuten, die in Deutschland in einem Beschäftigungsverhältnis sind, Daten wie Name, Geburtsdatum, Arbeitsbeginn, Arbeitsende, Urlaubstage, Krankheit, Krankheitsgrund, Streik und so weiter abgespeichert werden an einer zentralen Stelle und in Zukunft vom Arbeitsamt bis hin zu sonst was genutzt werden sollen.
Also eine Art bundesweite Stechuhr.
Also das ist ja elektronische Entgeltennachweis. Nur noch mal um den Namen Elena zu erzählen.
Aber Dominik, wie war es denn heute in Karlsruhe?
Wir haben uns heute Morgen in ein Hotel getroffen, haben eine Pressekonferenz gemacht, sind abgeschrieben zum Verfassungsgericht.
Und jetzt ist ein Verbindung gerade ein bisschen komisch. Kannst du ruhig stehen bleiben? Genau. Und jetzt noch mal von vorn.
Wir haben uns im Hotel getroffen. Gestern Abend sind wir heute Morgen zum Verfassungsgericht gefahren, nachdem wir eine Pressekonferenz gemacht haben. Und haben anschließend die Vollmachten mit 62 Ordnern abgegeben. Und haben versucht, das Thema nochmal in die große Öffentlichkeit rein zu drücken.
Ihr müsst einen Bollerwagen dabei gehabt haben, oder?
Das war ein größerer Bollerwagen.
Wie viel 62 Aktenordner voll?
Genau, 62 Leitzordner plus noch mal 5 Leitzordner Beschwerdeschrift. Um die Kurve zu bekommen zu dem Thema, das kann ganz prima genutzt werden, um Persönlichkeitsprofile anzulegen. Also nicht im Hinblick auf Kommunikationsdaten, sondern im Hinblick auf die Frage, was kann jemandem wirtschaftlich stemmen?
Du meinst jetzt Industrie-Spionage oder was?
Darauf läuft es wohl hinaus.
Ja, okay, dass man mit Arbeitnehmerdaten hervorragende Betriebsspionage betreiben kann und auch über die Arbeitnehmer eine Menge herausfindet, das ist, glaube ich, klar, wenn man fünf Minuten darüber nachdenkt. Aber wir schweifen schon wieder vom Thema ab und haben nicht mehr viel Zeit. Gibt es noch etwas ganz Großartiges heute aus Karlsruhe zu berichten? Außer, dass die Klage jetzt eingereicht ist?
Eingereicht und alle sind gespannt.
Die nächste Verfassungsschwerde ist also am Start, ist heute abgegeben worden und die Strategie ist quasi, wir bewerfen die Leute solange mit Papier, bis sie bluten. Wir haben jetzt noch zwei Minuten quasi.
Das müssen wir noch dementieren. Das Verfassungsgericht guckt schon, wie viele Leute sich für ein Thema interessieren. Gerade bei der Vorratsentsprechung war es schon ein wichtiger Punkt, dass sich so viele Leute dafür interessiert haben, dass sie so viele Leute engagiert haben. Insofern macht sowas tatsächlich auch schon Sinn.
Na ja, bei den Netzsperren ja wohl auch. Also ohne die Petitionen von den fast 140.000 Leuten hätten wir nie erreicht, was wir erreicht haben, nämlich, dass das Gesetz nicht angewendet wird. Das ist, was wir wollten und wir haben es hingekriegt.
Aber es ist tatsächlich sozusagen aufgrund der Petition, wobei...
Aber ich denke schon, dass die Gegenöffentlichkeit und auch die sachlichen Argumente, die wir von Pontius zu Pilatus getragen haben, dazu beigetragen haben. Es ist ja jetzt noch so, dass die Unionsfraktion im Bundestag der Schrecken in den Knochen steckt über diese öffentliche Empörung.
Also spezifisch bei so einem Thema, wo sie dachten, da ist kein ernsthafter Widerstand zu erwarten.
Ja, gerade bei diesem emotionalen, ja.
Und dann ist es ganz...
Worüber werden wir in einem Jahr an dieser Stelle reden?
Tja, vermutlich immer noch über die EU. Das ist völlig unklar. Die Prozesse in der EU können sehr schnell, aber sehr langsam passieren. Wenn jetzt da das Europäische Parlament auch ein Wörtchen mitzureden hat.
Na ja, außerdem müssen Schweden bald wahlen, nicht wahr? Das sind schwedische EU-Kommissare. Schweden hat eine sehr aktive Piratenpartei. Also, hey komm, wir kriegen das auch noch.
Okay, wir hatten jetzt zwei Stunden Spaß mit Netzsperren, einem ACTA-Geheimvertrag und einem Jugend-Bedien-Schutz-Staatsvertrag. Wir werden auch noch weiter mit Spaß haben, weil die EU mit drin hängen und dadurch ist es ein bisschen länger. Jetzt noch kurz ein Tipp, wenn jemand die Sendung zugehört hat und sich weiter zu dem Thema informieren will, wo geht er hin?
Also er kann sich zum einen an den ACTA-Zensur wenden. Der hat eine sehr umfangreiche Webseite und auch eine sehr große Wiki, wo auch mittlerweile mehrsprachig alles da ist. Eine große Plattform ist auch Mogis, der Verein, der auch sehr viele Sprachen hat. Und ich glaube aber, dass man schlicht auch Google benutzen kann, denn wir haben ein Jahr über diese Netzsperren gestritten. Wir hatten auch schon mal eine Sendung dazu, wo wir auch einige technische Details genannt haben. Genau, und Guzi hat noch eine Idee.
Ja, ich wollte noch mal kurz anmerken, wegen dem Jugendmedienstaatsvertrag, da gibt es eine Petition.
Genau.
Also es gibt 16 Petitionen, nämlich für jedes Bundesland eine. Man nehme Stift und Block und so bereit oder einfach mal eine Tastatur. Die Adresse lautet, ich diktiere. Http://www.zensur-in.de Da findet ihr alles andere. Das ist nicht von uns, aber ich finde, man sollte es mal sagen. Da will jemand irgendwie in 16 Landesparlamenten Petitionen einbringen. Also wenn ihr da mitmachen wollt und gegenseit unterschreiben könnt, dann helft dir da bestimmt, dass es nochmal auf die politische Agenda der Landtage kommt.
Da wisst ihr jetzt also wo es geht. Falls ihr die URL nicht genau verstanden habt, vielleicht trägt sie ja noch jemand ins Wiki ein. Hint, Hint, Hint.
Einverstanden.
Oder ihr guckt einfach nach dem Podcast, den gibt es in wenigen Stunden, auf fritz.de und dann bestimmt auch im Laufe der Woche auf chaosradio.de. Vielen Dank euch für sie gewesen sein.
Na, bitteschön.
Gerne doch.
Es war auch sehr schön, dass ihr zu früh gekommen seid.
Ich bringe noch nächstes Mal eine Mate mit.
Hey, das ist cool. Als nächstes kommen hier Smith und Smart. Und ich glaube, der Herr Smart hat eine neue Frisur, was ich ganz ungewöhnlich finde.
Der hat Gesichtshahre.
Na, der wird sich wahrscheinlich auch gleich auf eine längere Diskussion mit einer hier anwesenden Frau einlassen müssen. Das, was ich jetzt nicht näher kommentieren will. Ich sage vielen Dank euch auch fürs Zuhören und Mitmachen. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß im weiteren Verlauf der Nacht und sage bis zum nächsten Mal. Und macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.